ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز
ينص السلطن برج يقول بان اسرع طريق
للحل في اوكرانيا هو دعم اوكرانيا عسكريه
هل هذه المعادله صحيحه
يعني هذه المعادله يقابلها معادله روسيه
وبالتالي علينا ان نضع كلى المقاربتين
المقاربه الروسيه منذ تولي الجناره الشرقي
والجنر المفضل لدى الرئيس بوتن حاول ان
يعمل المزاوجه ما بين الطائرات القصيره
والصواريخ من اجل تحقيق امر ثلاثي يطلق
عليه الثلاثي المرعب وهو القصف الشتاء
والمجاعه وبالتالي حدوث هجره واغلاق
اوروبا من اجل احداث الضغط على القيادات
يقابله الان المقاربه الاوكرانيه كذلك
المقارنه الاوكرانيه هي تسند الى مقاربه
الرئيس الروسي كان نقاط ال 10 والتي من
ضمنها الانسحاب الكامل بما فيه جزيره
القرد يقابلها المقاربه السياسي الروسيه
من 13 بنت منها الاقرار بالواقع الميداني
ولا بل دفع تعويضات اذا ما هو المخرج
المخرج همم دعم اوكرانيا من اجل اجبار
روسيا على التراجع والاذعان وليس الاذعان
الاخراني هذا لا يتاذى الا باستمرار الدعم
العسكري والدعم الاقتصادي
تصريحات يا سيستمبر ايضا اشارت الى
مشروعيه الضربات الاوكرانيه في العمق
الروسي داخل روسيا هل تحتمل هذه العباره
من ينس- توتنبرج همم اكثر من مجرد الدعم
اللفظي هل هناك بعد اخر لهذا التصريح
يعني الان يقابل ذلك الرفض الاميركي وعدم
قبول تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه تطال العمق
الروسي وتقديم النصيحه بعدم تنفيذ ضربات
داخل العمق الروسي علما بعض التقارير
الامنيه اشارت الى موافقه امريكيه لقصف
قاعده انجلز الان فيما يتعلق بالجانب
الاوروبي يعني هو يقدم الكثير نظريا ويقدم
القليل على ارض الواقع على سبيل المثال
المانيا وعدت باربعه انظمه الصواريخ سلمت
واحده الدعم العسكري والاقتصاد الحقيقي من
امريكا وبالتالي اعتقد ان الرؤيه
الامريكيه هي التي سيتم الامتثال
الاوكراني لها وليس الاوروبيه علما ان
اوروبا لن تقدم الكثير من المعدات
والاسلحه واقصى مدى 30 كلم لو واقفه
استهداف قاعده انجلز بالاضافه الى سقوط
صاروخ في بيلاروسيا ما هي الرسائل
العسكريه التي تحاول اوكرانيا اصالها
يعني دعينا نفرق بين الامرين الان عندما
يتحدث عن قاعده انجلز نتحدث عن اهم قاعده
جويه تم تاسيس ساعه عام 1930 هي اهم قاعده
جويه في روسيا يوجد بها 19 قائده يو 160
او ما يطلق عليها البجعه البيضاء وروسيا
تمتلك فقط 19 طائره من هذا النوع وهي
الطائرات الاسراتيجيه ذات
المذايات البعيده وبالتالي النجاح في
استهدافها المره الاولى والثانيه ومحاوله
المره الثالثه يعني ان كافه الاهداف ضمن
مدى 1,000 كيلو متر هذه القاعده دي تبعد
730 لكن مدى الطائره 1000 كيلو متر وهي
الطائره
سوفيه محدث اوكرانيا تقع ضمن المدى الذي
يمكن استهدافه اذا توفرت الاعداد الان
سقوط الصاروخ في ااا في بيلاروسيا اعتقد
انه نفس الحاله التي حدثت في بولندا وانا
قلت حتى قبل الاعتراف او التصريح او
التفسير التقني انه صاروخ اس 300 سقط
بالخطا واعتقد ان هذا الصاروخ سقط بالخطا
شكرا لك فايز الدولي الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان